former le diabète de type 1 une maladie
qui ne prend pas une seconde de repos
d'imax doumit qu'on joue dans la ligue
nationale
où que l'on soit bien assis en classe le
défi reste le même très jeunes de 9 à 17
ans tous atteints de la maladie ont bu
les paroles de la vedette du canadien
domi a reçu son diagnostic à 12 le
hacker a mis du temps à digérer la
nouvelle
grâce entre autres à la légende des
flyers de philadelphie à son tour
d'insuffler un peu d'espoir le centre du
tricolore est devenu le porte parole de
l'organisme qui finance la recherche sur
la maladie le diabète de type 1 frappe
davantage les jeunes environ 1 sur 300
âgé de 19 ans et moins devra apprendre à
vivre avec cette réalité c'est le cas de
laurie diagnostiqué à 11
sincèrement le plus gros défi c'est
l'été les piqueurs j'ai une femme du
coeur qui à lyon parce que les jets les
choses comme ça juste devant mais piqué
plusieurs fois par jour ça a été un
grand défi l'adolescente mentionne aussi
les coûts énormes liés au traitement et
aux soins
tof une grande source de stress pour les
familles qui doivent débourser jusqu'à
15000 dollars par année
l'histoire de max domine allège
évidemment pas les factures mais la
porte tout de même un peu de réconfort
ça m'a vraiment donné du courage ça m'a
vraiment pris d'accord tu peux tu peux
faire quelque chose si tu es chez très
fort est ce que tu aimerais se jouer au
hockey ce que quelque chose que tu veux
tu aimerais vraiment vraiment faire dans
la vie comme le lui a appris domi il
faut maintenant y croire ici alexandre
gascon radio-canada à montréal